votre père c'est monsieur chirac se
confirme la presse étrangère allemande
américaine anglaise elle même maintenant
en parle et tout ceci rend de plus en
plus probable votre présence au deuxième
tour
cette présence passe vraisemblablement
par l'élimination de françois mitterrand
au premier tour et hier soir il semble
que le candidat sortant ce soit un peu
ému voire inquiété de cette élimination
de monsieur mitterrand
s'agit-il d'une espèce d'appel à voter
mitterrand au premier tour comment
réagissez-vous devant tout cela non je
ne crois pas que ce soit ce que monsieur
giscard d'estaing a voulu dire mais le
ferai simplement deux observations
la première c'est qu'il n'appartient pas
un candidat de désigner lui-même celui
qu'il souhaite affronter au deuxième
tour 7 au suffrage universel bien sûr de
le faire ensuite la situation dans
laquelle il n'y aurait au deuxième tour
ni candidat socialiste ni candidat
communiste
eh bien nous l'avons déjà connus
souvenez-vous de 1969 seuls étaient
restés en lice monsieur pompidou et
monsieur power et cela c'est très bien
placé et bien si au soir du 26 avril
cette situation se reproduit nous aurons
éliminer tout risque de changement de
société et c'est ce que nous souhaitons
et c'est ce que je vous propose
si vos propositions ont eu tellement
d'échos dans la population française
c'est sans doute qu'elles sont redonnés
aux autour de quelques idées simples et
fortes
par exemple relancer la production pour
créer des emplois supplémentaires ou
encore afin de lutter contre la
bureaucratie faire des économies et
diminuer les impôts en matière sociale
votre idée force c'est la solidarité
alors ce mot de solidarité qui lui est
un peu plus abstrait mérite sans doute
quelques explications
une politique sociale ne peut être
uniquement une politique d'assistance
c'est à dire une politique ou deux
la naissance jusqu'à la mort les
français verrait tout le risque pris en
charge par l'état
une politique sociale c'est une
politique de solidarité c'est-à-dire qui
renforce les liens qui doivent exister
entre les générations entre les
différents groupes sociaux qui soit plus
fraternelle en quelque sorte qui exige
plus de rapport de dialogue de
concertation entre eux et entre eux et
les pouvoirs publics
c'est ce que nous devons créer alors la
solidarité entre les générations qui est
la première forme peut-être de cette
solidarité
elle passe par une politique en faveur
des personnes âgées
ce que vous pensez que tout a été fait
dans ce domaine comme le dit parfois on
a dit que au cours de ce septennat on
avait fait beaucoup de choses et c'est
vrai mais on n'a pas fait l'essentiel et
on n'a pas fait suffisamment
les personnes âgées sont encore dans une
seule dans une situation où la solitude
leur baisse au moment même où la rupture
que constitue le passage de l'âge de la
retraite créé beaucoup de problèmes à
ceux qui franchissent cette ligne il
faut donc aujourd'hui aller plus loin
dans cet effort de solidarité
alors cet effort de solidarité et de
lutte contre la solitude c'est un état
d'esprit ne se sont aussi des mesures
concrètes destinées aux personnes âgées
ce que vous pourriez nous donner les
principales décisions concrètes je les
ai moi même expérimenté en les prenant
appris et je crois que personne ne peut
son plein il y a naturellement
l'augmentation à un niveau qui soit
convenable du minimum assuré à toutes
personnes âgées en matière de revenus il
y a l'exonération de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour toutes les pensions et
retraites de moins de 5000 francs pas
noir c'est une question de justice
sociale
il y a toutes les mesures qui touchent à
la façon dont la retraitée toucher plus
rapidement au moment où on l'apprend
mais aussi à la mensualisation
indispensable il y a le développement
et services à domicile je voudrais
pouvoir faire demain en france
ce que j'ai fait à ce sujet puis il ya
aussi une inquiétude qui est très
présent par esprit des personnes âgées
on les comprends c'est la sécurité
il y à la sécurité que cela intéresse
naturellement tous les français mais il
faut un renforcement des mesures et de
la volonté de l'état pour permettre de
garantir la sécurité des personnes et
des biens
c'est un objectif tout à fait
indispensable vous savez la france a
reçu de la génération qui nous a
précédés des générations qui nous après
celles qui nous ont précédés a reçu
quelque chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel
ces hommes et ces femmes qui se sont
battus pour nous à verdun pendant la
résistance à la libération nous ont
laissé une france grande et forte et en
bon état et notre ambition aujourd'hui
doit être de donner un autre tour une
france grande et forte à ceux qui nous
succéderont et je ne suis pas sûr que
nous soyons aujourd'hui en mesure de le
faire cela impose
d'une part un effort de redressement
économique pour rendre sa grandeur à
notre pays et cela impose également un
effort de reconnaissance de solidarité à
l'égard des générations qui nous ont
précédés mais il ya une catégorie qui
elle aussi se sent un peu à l'écart de
la communauté nationale et qui pourtant
on compte beaucoup de françaises et de
français à part entière ce sont les
handicapés oui et pour lesquels il faut
également faire un effort supplémentaire
je suis moi même responsable de deux
fondations importantes qui ont un
certain nombre de maisons pour
handicapés et je sais quelle est leur
problème
j'ai tenté de le résoudre pour partie à
paris il faut d'abord donner à ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'assumer leur
existence
le nécessaire pour qu'il se sente dans
cette société des français à part
entière
et puis il faut que ceux qui ont la
capacité de rendre service à la société
conçoit mis en mesure de le faire par
les aménagements qui s'impose sur le
plan du logement de la circulation de
l'urbanisme mais aussi
par la possibilité qui doit leur être
donné de travailler mieux et plus
complètement au service de la nation
c'est la réinsertion dans la société et
la participation exacte est exact alors
si l'on reprend un peu l'idée que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure de chaîne des
générations de solidarité entre les
classes d'âge vous avez parlé des
personnes âgées
à l'autre bout de la chaîne il ya ceux
qui vont recevoir cet héritage d'une
france grande et forte
ce sont les jeunes on nous dit beaucoup
que ils n'ont pas envie de s'engager qui
sont démobilisés est ce que c'est votre
sentiment
je ne crois pas qu'il soit eux qui ne
veulent pas s'engager
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'ils sont
démobilisés ils sont découragés et ceux
ci d'abord et avant tout parce qu'il
voit bien que cette société au moment où
ils veulent des engrais a tendance à
leur fermer ses portes notamment à cause
du développement du chômage
et lorsque les jeunes sont découragés
alors l'essentiel est en cause et je
vais parler des droits de la jeunesse
vous avez même une espèce de déclaration
des droits de la jeunesse oui je ne
donnais pas à ce mot droit naturellement
un sens juridique
je me le dire par là que nous avions à
les regarder obligations et ses
obligations c'est d'abord le droit au
travail le droit à l'emploi et pour cela
il faut prendre les mesures économiques
qui s'impose c'est le droit à la
formation également et à une formation
adaptée aux emplois qu'il est possible
de gray c'est aussi le droit au logement
qui est une des inégalités choquant de
notre temps et en tant que maire de
paris je le vois bien tous les jours
c'est également le droit à l'expression
il faut développer la vie associative et
lui donner les moyens de se développer
de façon à ce que se développe le
dialogue la concertation les échanges
nécessaires
il faut développer le sport dans lequel
les jeunes peuvent trouver ce qu'ils
aiment et ils sont nombreux
une forme d'expression il faut
développer aussi les formations et les
moyens d'expression culturelle c'est un
peu ce que vous avez fait à paris vous
avez créé des ateliers d'expression
culturelle louis état d'esprit je vois
que beaucoup de jeunes y vont parce que
c'est pour un mois
de s'épanouir c'est autre chose que la
simple société de consommation et il ya
enfin un autre droit et qui est le droit
à l'engagement
il y à de grandes et juste cause qui
mérite que l'on se mobilise pour elle
dans le monde
il y à la défense des droits de l'homme
qui de plus en plus sont bafoués un peu
partout y compris dans notre pays où
l'on voit ressurgir quelques tentations
raciste il y à la lutte contre la famine
dans le monde
il faut ouvrir ce champ large à la
générosité au dynamisme à la force à
l'ardeur de notre jeunesse
il faut l'encourager à se mobiliser pour
ces grandes et juste cause
il ya un dernier domaine peut être où la
notion de solidarité doit jouer un rôle
important car c'est le fondement de tout
ce qui a été fait depuis 30 ans je pense
au domaine de la santé et de la sécurité
sociale est ce qu'il n'ya pas là aussi
un lien de solidarité a renforcé entre
les cas les différentes catégories de
france est certainement et notamment par
une meilleure concertation la sécurité
sociale est aujourd'hui menacée et les
principes mêmes et notamment les
principes de notre médecine libérale
sont mis en cause est bien là aussi les
exigences de la solidarité sont que nous
fassions en sorte notamment par des
mesures économiques pour que tout ceci
ne soit pas menacé
ceci concerne les personnes âgées
beaucoup d'entre elles qui ne peuvent
être maintenues à domicile souhaite
pouvoir être accueillis dans les
établissements spécialement c'est bourré
et là il ya un problème qui a tendance à
se résoudre je le vois bien dans mon
département de la corrèze et les moyens
nécessaires sont encore à améliorer pour
que les maisons notamment les maisons de
cure médicale soit développée comme il
le faut alors si nous revenons
maintenant au domaine de la politique
nous sommes deux jours avant le premier
tour il faut bien en parler
j'aimerais que vous nous rappeler un peu
les points forts de la déclaration
politique importante que vous avez faite
hier à la presse eh bien d'abord
j'aurais voulu que tous nos concitoyens
comprennent que tout va se jouer au
premier tour
et qu'au premier tour il faut éliminer
tout risque d'un changement de société
que nos concitoyens ne souhaite pas dans
leur immense majorité
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle je
leur ai fait un appel un appel à tous
ceux et à toutes celles qui ont soutenu
l'action du général de gaulle l'action
de georges pompidou et qui sont attachés
au principe de la vème république un
appel à toutes celles et à tous ceux qui
souhaitent le spa stabilité dans notre
vie politique qui souhaitent le maintien
des vertus d'initiative de
responsabilité de liberté mais qui ont
bien conscience qu'aujourd'hui un
renouveau s'impose à toutes celles et à
tous ceux enfin qui sont attachés à tout
ce que comporte de grand et de généreux
les idéaux de justice du socialisme et
de l'humanisme de telle sorte qu'il
puisse être associé à cet effort sans
prendre le risque de voir demain le
parti communiste associé au pouvoir
c'est assez française et ses français
que je dis de se rassembler pour
renforcer l'image d'une france grande
forte et stable ce qui est capital c'est
que je propose le renouveau dans la
sécurité
je sais que notre peuple a la force et
la volonté de le faire et ce que je
voudrais demain c'est que les françaises
et les français soit fier et heureux
d'être français